this video is brought to you by Wix
what's up guys Jared here we're always
getting requests from fans saying you
guys have got to cover insert movie TV
show video game mean book sarcastic joke
here
well then enthusiastically watch it
brainstorm for a really long time and
often come up empty-handed it's not that
we can't think of anything the show
might hint at ideas but not fully
develop them or evidence keeps coming up
refuting our argument or sometimes a
show is just plain inconsistent or hey
maybe we're just too dumb to figure it
out so when it came time to look at
Netflix is surreal retro futuristic love
story we didn't quite get where we hoped
we dug and dug and found some really
cool stuff but a cohesive philosophy of
not quite so we're gonna do something a
bit different we're gonna go through the
ideas we considered show how and when
they work within the context of the show
and why we ultimately decided not to go
with it and hey maybe this will serve as
a foundation for you to think about the
show in new ways this is another
experiment for us so be sure to let us
know what you think in the comments and
without further ado welcome to the
inaugural episode of wisecrack
half-baked edition on super bad to
maniac and yep spoilers ahead but before
we get into that I want to give a quick
shout-out to our sponsor Wix Wix allows
you to build a great looking website
whether you're a freelancer looking to
showcase your skills or you're just
looking to share unused footage of
yourself tied up in a dank basement
either way it's legit free to get
started just head to wix.com slash
wisecrack to sign up and now back to the
show
alright guys so first a quick recap is
in order
wish me luck maniac primarily focuses on
Owen Milgram and Annie Landsberg Owen
the schizophrenic black sheep of a very
wealthy family struggles with delusions
of saving the world and a made-up
brother Annie a broke girl with a
dysfunctional family struggles with drug
addiction to cope with the death of her
sister and the estrangement of her
mother they enter a highly experimental
pharmaceutical study run by three
doctors and a supercomputer called
gertie that hopes to eradicate
psychological pain by having patients
identify map
ultimately confront their issues through
drug-induced fantasies Antion Owens
wires get crossed causing them to
inhabit each other's fantasies where
they experience whole lifetimes together
the gurdy gets depressed after the death
of dr. Moreau moto threatening the
experiment and the subjects inside the
final fantasy and he comforts the
computer finds the resolve to move past
her sister's death while Owen confronts
the fact that his fantasy brother is
just an idealized version of his crappy
real brother he saves the other patients
and back in the real world finds the
confidence to stand up to his family in
the end
Annie's friendship inspires Owen to
escape from a psych ward and have faith
in his ability to function or was that a
fantasy all right now on to the pitches
organized from best to worst for your
entertainment pitch one Don Quixote this
one is an 8 out of 10 almost good enough
for a video Miguel de Cervantes's modern
classic is everywhere in maniac one of
the fantasy scenarios even revolves
around Owen and Andy infiltrating a
seance to find the fictional lost final
chapter of the novel so why this focus
on an old book well let's break it down
Don Quixote tells the story of Alonso
Quijano who becomes so obsessed with
books about chivalry that his mind dries
out essentially he goes mad which makes
this line extra ironic I'm gonna read
you this time because I am healthy Annie
now and healthy people read books
inspired by his books Alonso decides to
become a knight errant himself the bulk
of the book follows him as he goes on
wild adventures including the one where
he famously attacks windmills he
mistakes his Giants windmills happens to
be the name of Maineiacs second episode
which briefly features Annie looking at
some during the road trip that ends in
her sister's death but trust me it gets
deeper than that already we can draw a
parallel between the madness that makes
Don Quixote want to perform heroic acts
and Owens schizophrenia that makes him
believe that he will save the world like
Don Quixote Owen can't distinguish
reality from fiction but more than that
Don Quixote inhabits a dreamlike
mindspace that makes castles of ends and
Giants of windmills
turning the regular world into a
fantastic one
similarly the ULP treatment turns its
patients sad realities into fully
fledged fantasy adventures
Annie's lemur painting becomes a bizarre
recovered the lemur story the copy of
Don Quixote she picks up becomes the
steal the final chapter plot Annie and
Ellie watching a Lord of the Rings esque
show becomes this and Owens Hawk that
kills Ernie the gerbil inspires the save
the world from aliens hail I would know
I was a secret agent but perhaps the
most powerful connection between the two
works is the shared theme of
transformation through the power of
dreams congratulations you're healed in
the case of the Don's delusions he
adventures so that he may reinvigorate a
Golden Age when people were more
authentic as he says blessed the time
and blessed the centuries called by the
ancients the Golden Age and that time
women spoke their thoughts of love from
the soul simply and pretentiously
exactly as they thought them not
searching for elaborate verbal
circumlocutions to beautify them truth
and simplicity were unmixed with fraud
deceit and malice justice remained firm
and sure neither troubled nor offended
against by patronage and self-interest
as today she is so grievously tainted in
troubled and persecuted judges did not
feel themselves as they do today
entitled to be tyrants if Don Quixote
fantasies represents his yearning for
the days when people weren't foolish
then one could say the ULP experiment
uses fantasy to heal a society that has
been defined by isolation as James
suggests at the beginning all levels of
physics require collision and bonding in
order to progress and so does the human
heart camaraderie Communion family
friendship love what-have-you we're lost
with a connection
it's quite terrible to be alone however
the world were presented is one that is
tragically absent meaningful connection
hello mrs. Finkelstein golf Donovan it's
the first two episodes introduce a
vision of New York in which people are
more alienated from each other than ever
most of the human interactions we
witness are purely transactional this is
made quite literal with friend proxy a
service that provides you with someone
pretending to be your friend for a feed
you're using a service that gives you
pretend friends I have real friends this
is just more convenient then there's ad
buddy where a human being pitches you a
product in exchange for goods and
services it's kind of like getting free
content on the internet but having to
watch annoying ads there even appears to
be a market for people to escape the
world entirely enter a void a box that
basically allows you to hibernate your
life away instead of engaging with the
outside world
there's also lines like this thank you
for braving the outside world and the
fact that a zoo me and James sleep in
isolating drawers the encroachment of
consumerism into every facet of our
lives is further emphasized by the
omnipresent of advertisements from the
ads that purchased Annie's face to the
neon signs blaring through Owens window
to ad copy on bridges in Maineiacs New
York you can't even take a [ __ ] without
being bludgeoned by ads so Don Quixote
uses fantasy to bring back an ideal era
of authentic expression and maniac
portrays two lonely souls finding
connection through fantasy in an era of
isolation you don't listen
I won't it's important to note that in
many of the ULP fantasies taking place
in the quote real world all the creepy
retro futuristic seems to disappear when
trying to save her lemur for instance
the world goes from what the 80s thought
the 2000s would look like to just the
80s but there's an important
qualification to mention here
this Golden Age the Don Quixote waxes
poetic about never really happened there
are many characters in the book who've
been moaned the negative effects of
chivalry books deeming them trash and
assuring people that there was never
such an idyllic time I can swear to you
that in fact this world has never seen a
single one of those Knights nor any of
their grand deeds or their stupidities
and the end Don Quixote is tricked into
hanging up his Lance and becoming Alonso
Quijano again eventually renounces his
madness and dies a quiet death similarly
an E ends up rejecting Gerdes offer to
stay in the fantasy world with her
sister she accepts reality and together
with Owen moves forward confidently
anywhere here the problem with this is
that although it's clear that Annie's
break from fantasy is considered a
positive development for her character
there's more ambiguity surrounding the
conclusion of Don Quixote are we
supposed to agree with the bulk of the
characters in the book who claim that
fantasy has done nothing but make him a
fool is it good that he's no longer out
adventuring or should we look at it like
Don Antonio Moreno who says may God
forgive you for the damage you've done
to the whole rest of the world in trying
to cure the wittiest lunatic ever seen
don't you see my dear sir that whatever
utility there might be in curing him it
could never match the pleasure he gives
with his madness so why wasn't this made
into a full video well despite these
really great connections what else is
there to say that reality is better than
being a McMurphy that fantasy is a
liberating force for Humanity it seems
like the connection between the two
works is they both vaguely deal with the
nature of fantasy versus reality but not
in a way that could really provide a
definitive philosophical thesis pitch to
mommy daddy and me I give us 1 a 5 out
of 10
up top we should mention Owens name his
surname Milgram is a reference to the
Milgram experiment in which subjects
were given the ability to electrocute
people and continued to harm them under
the suggestion of an authority figure
pretty cool shout out but we didn't
really see how it connected to any of
the events in this
series there's also some serious
Freudian undertones James is a
paraphilic meaning he's attracted to
inanimate objects he also has a strange
relationship with his mother in fact if
we want to get all oedipal and we always
do the oedipal triangle of mother father
and child seem to be important for many
of the main characters
Annie's mother walked out on her father
Owens dad is an overbearing fascist and
mantle ray also without a father in his
life you drove my father away and you
slept in my bed way too much literally
goes blind after confronting his mother
I can't see not so different than say a
tragic figure who stabs his eyes out
after romancing his Madre he also built
a computer modeled on its mother's mind
and while that's not in the Greek
tragedy it seems pertinent the computer
is you what the ULP test also functions
on the idea that our mental ailments can
mostly be attributed to some unresolved
trauma for freud many of our neuroses
and mental health problems were brought
on by unresolved trauma that we must
work through the three stages of the ULP
treatment take a similar approach but
with the mapping and confrontation
stages being more fantasy lives and less
laying on the couch talking about your
mom but the connection we really wanted
to make was to a pair of thinkers who
were strongly opposed to Freud's method
philosopher geo doulas and his
psychoanalyst sidekick Felix Guattari
the three things that got our spidey
senses tingling were one the use of the
term arborisation to describe the method
they used to map the brain to there are
bonsai trees everywhere and three the
opening monologue suggests that the
universe and life are a chaotic series
of collisions for Deleuze and Guattari
the dominant way of thinking about the
world is arborescent that is resembling
a tree we often think about history and
society like a tree starting at a trunk
and growing in a mostly linear fashion
while occasionally branching but Deleuze
and Guattari preferred another natural
metaphor the rhizome rhizomes are the
roots of plants like ginger or weeds
like dandelions the important thing
about rhizomes is that they look like a
series of connections
no visible starting point like to say
the roots of the tree basically the
world is too complex to be understood
linearly instead of simple cause and
effect
there's inputs outputs feedback loops
and a lot of chaos that we barely
understand so why does this matter for
maniac well in some cases we could view
the opening monologue under this
framework life isn't so much a straight
line as it is a chaotic assortment of
random connections like the structure of
a rhizome the crossing of wires were
Owen and Andy kind of follow this logic
the straight line of their computers
connections are interrupted by a random
connection bonsai trees in theory would
be an interesting addition to the
symbolism not only is it defined by
linearity and branching but that
branching is intentionally guided by a
human hand maybe we could say that the
show ends up somewhere in the middle
between the totally chaotic rhizome and
the guided branching of the bonsai tree
after all Andy starts the show saying
there is no plan or pattern to the
universe it's just chaos and ends the
show saying this this is a sign
friend Burke's going we ultimately
abandon this idea because we couldn't
find any evidence that linked the bonsai
trees to the couple times that chaos
versus order is referenced we had a few
other clues too but they went nowhere
for instance de la xin Guattari are well
known for their book and the Oedipus
which challenges people who sought to
analyze the world in Freudian terms
specifically they wanted to break free
of the oedipal triangle mommy daddy and
me and mantle ray after interpreting his
blindness as a symptom of his mother's
behaviors rejects this Freudian framing
and accepts that it was instead brought
on by a kiss from Azumi there's also
this probably random coincidence Felix
Guattari wrote a screenplay called
a love of uiq which at least sounds kind
of like you LP about a subatomic
consciousness that inhabits a computer
and falls in love with a human
plus the loves and guattari used
schizophrenia as a model to think about
the world where our desires were not Lim
by the confines of society or say
capitalism and yeah maniac shows a kind
of dystopian capitalism and there's a
guy with schizophrenia but it doesn't
quite work pitch three Oh in
schizophrenia yeah this one's the worst
now opposed to the loves and guattari
notion of schizophrenia which we need to
say is not exactly literal to the
medical condition there's Frederick
Jameson's rebuttal to them Jamison
suggests that when people are so
bombarded with commercial images and
messages about who they can be or how a
product will make them into this or that
person they're actually imposing
competing ideas of identity onto them
therefore this causes a perpetually
shifting identity or a schizophrenic
subject and the more one's identity
vacillates the more one consumes
therefore the schizophrenic subject is
ideal for such an economic system
encompass mentis there's little doubt
that the show hints at a causal
connection between advanced consumer
capitalism and isolation but is maniac
using Owens schizophrenia as a metaphor
for the ills heaped upon the denizens of
the dystopia no definitely a stretch
it's interesting but there's no evidence
we could point to to make a confident
case just because we couldn't come up
with a cogent argument about the show's
grander messages doesn't mean it isn't a
good show nor does it mean it isn't a
smart show there are some extremely
clever things going on the constant
easter-egg references that connect the
dreams not only to other dreams but to
real life the focus on how narrative
builds meaning in our lives our brains
adjust and the small details at the end
that make us question the validity of
the real world above others get it like
Wendy the Lemur what makes maniacs so
impressive is its daring visual
aesthetic it's formless structure and
its regular dips into absurdity and for
that we can't help but admire it it
sticks to a relatively simple thematic
base and runs with it that people need
connection and it's our ability to bond
that can give us hope to beat our demons
that's all for now let us know what you
think about our half-baked format and as
always thanks for watching
but before you go we want to give a
shout out to Wix the website building
platform that allows you to create a
website for any occasion from the
student trying to showcase their
research to the advanced designer
creating a portfolio masterpiece Wix
enables you to make a professional and
unique webpage also it's completely free
to get started
Wix will enable you to create a
professional and unique web page we also
found that they were the perfect place
to host our main page but while that's
still under construction we've used
their community features to create a
temporary site so you can vote on what
you think we should do next right now if
you head to the link in the description
you can decide on which bin jabal
Netflix show we should cover on our
movie podcast show me the meaning yeah I
know it's her movies but hey we're
trying something new
we'd have a lot of fun creating these
pages and love hearing your feedback get
started by creating your own website for
free by clicking here or visiting Wix
comm slash wisecrack
[Music]